plan massif de la bce pour sauver la
zone euro chèque aux ménages américains
pour soutenir la consommation est depuis
quelques jours les banques centrales et
les gouvernements se mobilisent pour
contenir les effets dévastateurs de la
crise du coronavirus qui n'écarte pas
pour autant les risques de récession et
peine à calmer les marchés financiers
ces mesures sans précédent seront elles
suffisantes pour éviter un effondrement
quel monde économique se dessine au delà
de cette épidémie on voit ça tout de
suite avec l'économiste jacques sapir
dans son édito une fois n'est pas
coutume par skype à un confinement
oblige cher jacques on va s'y habituer
avec toutes nos excuses évidemment de ne
pas vous recevoir
sur ce plateau alors jacques crise
menaçant de paralyser
comment vous voyez les choses
eh bien vous savez stephenie faut
d'abord dire que la situation est
complètement inédite
outre la crise des marchés financiers
dont on a déjà parlé ici c'est le
passage ou confinement des divers pays
qui met les économies en sommeil le
risque évidemment et qu'elle ne se
réveille pas une fois l'épidémie passé
c'est un peu ce que j'appelle moi le
syndrome où les fées blanche-neige tout
le monde connaît le compte
le virus est bien ça serait l'équivalent
de la pomme qui plonge blanche neige
dans le sommeil et les sept nains les
banquiers centraux qui ne peuvent pas
faire grand-chose ouamane qui ne peuvent
rien faire alors on le sait dans la vie
réelle il n'y a pas de prince charmant
mais il y à l'état il faut donc
permettre aux salariés et aux
entreprises de traverser cette période
dans les moins mauvaises conditions
seulement on peut se demander si les
mesures qui sont qui seront prises
évidemment ne dessine pas en réalité une
économie très différente de ce que nous
connaissions avant cette épidémie alors
jacques comment évaluez vous les
réponses données jusqu'ici
à cette crise vous il faut commencer
tout d'abord par voir un petit peu ce
qui se passe et vous êtes vous savez une
des choses c'est la trajectoire que me
suivant alors une chose qui est très
intéressante c'est de regarder les
cartes de la contamination et on voit
que presque systématiquement ce sont les
régions les plus développées qui sont
touchés comme en italie par exemple on
va le voir cette contamination elle est
très grave où elle est très grave dans
le nord qui est la région la plus
industrielle du pays
d'ailleurs c'était un petit peu la même
chose parce que en chine
l'épidémie elle a commencé à oye mba one
c'est le berceau de l'industrie
automobile chinoise avec toutes ses
usines
alors jacques est pourquoi ces mesures
de confinement sont elles en train de
plonger l'économie dans une forme de
léthargie bien si vous voulez ses fans
il encore il faut bien regarder comment
ça se passait et comment sont les cartes
si vous regardez la carte de l'italie
mais aussi si vous regardez la carte de
la contamination en allemagne
c'est une carte qui est un petit peu
plus anciennes je n'ai pas trouvé de
cartes plus récente malheureusement eh
bien ce sont les régions qui sont le qui
ont le plus de relation directe ou
indirecte avec la chine qui sont touchés
les premières en allemagne qui est un
gros partenaire industriel de la chine
la carte de la contamination correspond
en réalité aux régions les plus
mondialisées
en fait c'est le va et vient des
ingénieurs des quatre commerciaux des
techniciens break qui a rapporté le
virus et à partir de là ces régions ont
progressivement contaminé le reste du
pays en france d'ailleurs il faut le
rappeler
la première région touchée l'oise l'a
aussi aidé du fait de gens rentrant de
chine
alors jacques comment cela
s'explique-t-il et bien comme je le dis
c'est évidemment le problème général
du commerce de la mondialisation mais ce
qui me semble aussi le plus intéressant
c'est de regarder les risques de
récession
et quelle ampleur elle pourrait avoir et
bien prenons le cas de l'exemple chinois
la consommation d'énergie a chuté là bas
à moins de 40 % de son niveau normal
comme les gens qu'on finit doivent
continuer de se chauffer de s'éclairer
on peut penser que en réalité c'est
pratiquement 80% de l'industrie et des
différentes activités économiques qui
ont été à l'arrêt si on transpose ce que
l'on a connu en chine en france ou en
italie
ça voudrait dire que momentanément la
production de richesse va baisser dans
notre pays ou en italie de 20 à 30 % sur
le premier et le deuxième semestre alors
là encore quels sont les secteurs qui
vont être les plus touchés on les voit à
l'écran l'industrie bidamant va être
touché tant par les effets du
confinement qui arrête les usines que
par le manque des pièces détachées dans
les usines qui fonctionne encore pour le
bâtiment et travaux publics
on voit que ce sont les principaux
chantiers qui sont aujourd'hui arrêter
ou fortement ralenti on sait que madame
pénicaud c'en est inquiété mais on voit
bien que les différentes entreprises de
construction peut faire difficilement
autre chose que de s'arrêter
et puis c'est évidemment pour les
services et le commerce
mis à part évidemment l'alimentaire et
les pharmacies que l'impact des mesures
de confinement est et sera le plus
dramatique
alors jacques concrètement quelles
peuvent être les conséquences pour les
entreprises comme pour les salariés
alors on va commencer par les
entreprises pour les entreprises a
d'abord elles vont plus avoir deux
rentrées d'argent par contre leurs
emprunts courent toujours
donc il y a un problème immédiat de
liquidité au delà de ce problème
il va y avoir un problème de solvabilité
en effet les entreprises n'ont plus de
revenus mais elles doivent toujours
payer leurs employés les frais fixes et
herat si cela dure
la survie de très nombreuses entreprises
sera mise en question
vous savez
en italie d'ores et déjà on annonce une
possibilité de faillite pour 12 % des
pme italiennes après il ya le problème
pour les salariés le problème se pose
d'abord pour gérer les salariés des
entreprises
évidemment ça va poser la question du
chômage technique ou partiel et on sait
déjà que mardi dernier il y avait à peu
près deux millions de salariés qui
étaient concernés mais le problème le
plus important
il va se poser pour les travailleurs
indépendants les auto-entrepreneurs et
là ça risque d'être encore plus
dramatique
alors jacques le gouvernement a pris des
mesures lesquels et pourquoi faire alors
c'est vrai le gouvernement a pris
beaucoup de mesures et il a assez bien
réagi à l'urgence économique
si on fait la liste des mesures mais on
va voir quelle est relativement complet
en réalité on voit que ces mesures cours
les principaux risques ajoute aussi la
déclaration faite cette semaine par le
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
qui a évoqué la possibilité d'une
nationalisation partielle ou totale
on pense par exemple à air france le
seul point faible pour l'instant
concerne évidemment la question du
revenu des travailleurs indépendants
mais ça va coûter évidemment très cher
jacques on imagine et bien oui
ah oui vous avez tout à fait raison et
stéphanie le gouvernement parle de 45
milliards d'euros dette directe plus 300
milliards de garanties de crédit
en allemagne on annonce déjà plus de 500
milliards d'euros en garanties de crédit
en italie le parlement a déjà voté une
loi qui prévoit 25 milliards
des directs et ce n'est qu'un début
alors oui vous avez tout à fait raison
ça va coûter très cher le président de
la république avait annoncé des mesures
quoi qu'il en coûte vous rappeler cette
formule a été répétée trois fois dans
son intervention du 12 mars
et bien voila quoi qu'il en coûte nous y
sommes le ministère des finances estime
que le déficit va monter à 3 9% du pib
cette année mais vous savez
quand on sait qu'en 2009 et en réponse
d'ailleurs à la crise des subprimes
à l'époque le déficit avait été de plus
de 7%
il est très probable en réalité que l'on
sera largement au-dessus de 4% du
déficit à la fin de l'année et la
question évidemment
qui va payer et oui bonne question c'est
fait on en revient toujours là et vous
avez tout à fait raison
alors la banque centrale européenne a
fait très fort avec un plan massif de
750 milliards d'euros de rachats de
titres de dette publique et privée
elle devrait donc certainement acquérir
directement des bons du trésor qu'ils
soient français italien allemand ou
espagnol
cependant on sait bien que sur ce
problème et c'est vrai que ça met en
cause directement la charte qui fixe
l'organisation de la banque centrale
européenne il y à des résistances
en particulier il faut bien le dire du
côté allemand et du côté néerlandais
cette question du financement va donc
être au coeur des débats dans l'union
européenne
dès la fin du printemps ou ou le début
de c'était justement jacques vont
apporter tout trouvé ma transition
l'union européenne dans tout ça alors eh
oui stéphanie l'union européenne eh bien
on peut la qualifier de grande muette de
grandes absentes
on constate que les pays de l'union
européenne gère cette crise
individuellement l'union européenne a
été incapable de réagir que ce soit au
niveau sanitaire mais aussi au niveau
économique
la ce a des conséquences déjà en italie
l'opinion est en train de tourner
franchement hostile 1 union européenne
67 % des italiens pensent que
l'appartenance à l'ue eux est un
problème alors que seulement 21 % des
italiens estiment qu'elle est un
avantage si les règles de l'euro ne sont
pas rapidement modifiées et si le statut
de l'union européenne ne
oublie pas des transformations
importantes une nouvelle crise de l'euro
surviendra dès 2021 alors jacques que
vous nous raconter c'est on l'entend
comme ça un changement énorme qui se
prépare oui effectivement
en fait on goût on le voit bien c'est
toute la construction européenne de
l'union européenne elle-même à l'euro
qui est aujourd'hui ébranlé par ce crise
et qui devra rapidement changer ou périr
au delà cette crise
elle signe le retour du politique
rappelons-nous encore les déclarations
du 12 mars on du 16 mars d'emmanuel
macron mais c'est aussi le retour de
l'état dans l'économie
par exemple sur la question des
nationalisations
bref cette crise elle signe aussi une
mise en cause assez radicale de la
mondialisation car on voit bien que
c'est la notion de souveraineté
nationale de souveraineté sanitaire de
souveraineté dans le domaine de la santé
pour commencer qui est à l'oeuvre et
vous savez on ne reviendra sans doute
pas en arrière une fois cette crise
terminée merci jacques en tout cas pour
votre analyse qui donne à réfléchir
merci à vous et à bientôt
vous peut-être pas bientôt d'ailleurs
sur ce plateau toujours parce qu'il peut
objectivement mais on voit là on a on
est quand même votre chronique c'est
parfait comme ça
merci à vous je le prenais soin de vous